[clears throat]
>> We conclude Virgil's The Aeneid today.
And as we discussed,
Virgil is very much the anti-Homer.
And so,
what
The Aeneid
is is really a a response
to the Iliad and the Odyssey. Remember,
Homer believes that love is the unifying
force of the universe. It is a center.
It's what gives you life. It It's what
gives you purpose and hope.
For Virgil, what matters is the idea of
piety
or obedience
to
the gods
and to your father.
And um
as we discussed, Virgil sets up a very
stark contrast between love and piety
where they are competing forces.
You cannot love and be pious at the same
time.
And piety is ultimately the
the main centralizing force of the
universe. If you are pious, if you obey
the gods, then the world will be right
because the gods have a divine
plan for the world. And in the case of
the Aeneid, it is the founding of the
empire of Rome, which is Aeneas's
um mission and purpose.
And so, our role, our responsibility,
our duty in life is just to follow this
path
of the gods. And then the world will be
perfect.
Okay?
Um
This will the the Aeneid will create the
Roman Empire,
which will then become the Catholic
Church.
And the Catholic Church will rule for
over a thousand years, okay? The
millennium.
And during this thousand years, it is a
time of
uh
conformity, of stagnation. And it is
because in this time,
what is often referred to as the Dark
Ages, Virgil becomes the god
of the Catholic Church, the central
organizing force. Why? Because
every
children, sorry, every child of the
elite memorizes
the Aeneid.
And so, every child perceives the world
through the lens of the Aeneid.
And um so, what happened is to destroy
this empire, a man will emerge to
liberate the human imagination. And his
name, of course, is Dante.
And and Dante will destroy the Roman
Empire and the Catholic Church with his
masterpiece, The Divine Comedy. We will
spend the rest of the semester reading
The Divine Comedy. This is not something
you can read by yourself. There's
actually no point. You know, if I just
give it to you and say, "Go read it." It
will make no sense to you. We have to go
through line by line, word by word for
you to understand The Divine Comedy.
Because not only is it poetry, but
philosophy.
And what poetry will tell you is that a
poem is this truth
told with as few beautiful words as
possible. So, it could just be a few
lines, but it could take you a lifetime
before you understand the true meaning
of these lines. And that is what The
Divine Comedy is. It's a very
um it's an epic poem, but each
paragraph, each sentence but each um
each line is a truth, an eternal truth
onto itself, okay? So, we'll read The
Divine Comedy line by line
um and we'll try to really understand
it. But again, the point of this class
is not to tell you what the great books
are. The entire point of the class is to
get you excited about
entering the journey that is great
books. That will that will
take your entire lifetime, okay?
It will take your entire lifetime to
appreciate the the genius of these great
books. And
um this class is is meant to be a
starting point, okay? So, do not think
at the end of of this class, "Oh, I've
read Homer. I've read Virgil. I've read
Dante Dante, so I know the great books."
No, okay? This is just beginning.
All right. So, where we are in the story
of the Aeneid is
that Aeneas gets gets shipwrecked
um and he becomes a a guest of Dido, the
queen of Carthage.
And the two fall in love. Dido falls in
love with the fact that Aeneas is not
just a great warrior and very handsome,
but also be because he's a great
storyteller. He tells her the story of
the fall of uh Troy.
And the two fall in love. And Dido has
this burning passion for Aeneas. And the
gods and the gods uh
um
basically Juno wants to thwart the
possibility of the rise of the Roman
Empire. And so, uh she conspires to have
Dido and and Aeneas consummate their
passion for each other. And then they
get married. But then
uh
Jove, the king of the gods, finds out
about this and says, "No, no, no. This
is not part of the plan. Aeneas is not
supposed to fall in love with Dido, stay
in Carthage, and build the Carthaginian
Empire. He's supposed to go to Rome."
So, he sends Mercury, the messenger of
the gods, down to um
Aeneas and tells him, "Hey, man, what
are you doing? This is not your duty. Do
your duty, okay? So,
um
this is where we are
>> [snorts]
>> in the story, okay? So, let us um read,
okay? Uh I will read please.
Mercury Mercury lashes out at once.
You so now you lay foundation stones for
the soaring walls of Carthage,
building her gorgeous city, doting on
your wife,
>> [snorts]
>> blind to your own realm, oblivious to
your fate.
The king of the gods, whose power sways
earth and sky,
he is the one who sends me down from
brilliant Olympus, bearing commands for
you through the racing winds.
What are you plotting now?
Wasting time in Libya, what hope
misleads you so?
If such a glorious destiny cannot fire
your spirit,
if you will not shoulder the task for
your own fame, at least remember
Ascanius rising into his prime, the
hopes you lodge in Iulus, your only
heir. Okay, all right. So, Ascanius, of
course, is Aeneas's father, and Iulus is
the son, okay? Who will inherit
the
um legacy. You want to go on?
You owe him Italy's realm, the land of
Rome.
These orders still on his lips, the god
vanished from sight into empty air.
Then Aeneas was truly overwhelmed by the
vision, stunned, his hackles bristle
with fear, his voice chokes in his
throat.
He yearns to be gone, to desert this
land he loves,
thunderstruck by the warnings, Jupiter's
command.
But what can he do? What can he dare say
now to the queen in all her fury and win
her over? Where to Where to begin? What
opening?
Thoughts racing here, there, probing his
options, turning to this plan, that
plan, torn in two until at his wit's
end, this answer seems the best. Okay.
So, again, Virgil is the
anti-Homer. And what I mean by that is
that if Homer were writing this, then
what Homer would emphasize is how
emotional emotionally conflicted Aeneas
is because he loves Dido. He does not
want to go.
For Homer, love is above the gods.
And what a human is is someone who
aspires to love. And when we read The
Divine Comedy, what we will discover is
this The reason why is because
God is love, okay?
And there's an aspect of God in us, a
candle that strives to return to the
light. And so, we seek love. And so, for
Homer, given the choice between
going to Rome and founding a great
empire or staying in Carthage and being
with Dido, obviously, you choose Dido
because that is the path to God.
Right? And that's what happened in the
Odyssey where Odysseus had an
opportunity to stay with Calypso and
have uh and live forever,
uh but he chooses to return to Penelope.
And when he he returns Penelope,
Penelope asks him, "Will you ever leave
me again?" And she And he says, "Never
again will I leave you because this is
my home. Love is where my heart is."
Okay? So, this is the
um So, but what the conflict is in
Aeneas is, "Okay, I want to get the hell
out of here. I'm freezing with fear
because
what I fear most is the anger of the
gods. What I must do is be loyal to the
gods and heed their command. So, screw
love. I don't need that. But, there's a
problem, which is how do I actually
tell Dido, all right? That's a conflict.
Not should I leave Dido, but like how do
I get out of here without her bitching
at me?
All right?
And so, what does he decide to do? He
decides
I won't tell her.
Yeah, that's it. I'll pretend this
didn't happen, and then at night I will
just sneak away, and then
well, who cares what happens afterwards.
All right? So, this is So, the thing to
notice is this is not human, okay?
There's nothing human about Aeneas.
What he is is he's a he's a
walking phallus almost.
He's like James Bond now, you know?
He goes around, does his mission, sleeps
with with a lot of girls, and then runs
off.
All right?
So,
uh let us continue.
Uh um
Uh Ivory?
He summons Mnestheus, Sergestus,
Cloanthus, Serestus, gives them orders.
Fit out the fleet, but not a word.
Muster the crews on shore, all tackle
set to sail, but the cause for our new
course, you keep it secret.
Yet, he himself, since Dido, who means
the world to him, knows nothing, never
dreaming such a powerful love could be
uprooted. He will try to approach her,
find a moment to break the news gently,
a way to soften the blow that he must
leave.
All shipmates snap to commands, glad to
do his orders.
True, but the queen
who can delude a lover, soon caught wind
of a plot afoot.
The first to sense the Trojans are on
the move. She fears everything now, even
with all secure.
Rumor, vicious as ever, brings her word,
already distraught, that Trojans
>> Sorry. Sorry. Um you know what?
Uh
Sorry.
>> [clears throat]
>> Uh Ivory? Are rigging out their galleys,
gearing to set sail. She rages in She
rages in helpless frenzy, blazing
through the entire city, raving like
some mad
mad that
driven wild when the women shake the
sacred emblems, when the cyclic orgy
shouts of Bacchus fire her
on and s-
Cithaeron. Cithaeron echoes round with
maddened midnight cries. Okay. All
right. So, certain things to notice,
okay?
Bacchus
is the god of creativity
of um
god of creativity for the Greeks.
So, there's actually two gods of
creativity in the Greek world. There's
Apollo and there's Dionysus, Bacchus,
okay?
Apollo is the god of logical creativity,
where you sit down calmly and then you
write down your thoughts, okay? That's
Apollo. Then you have Bacchus, who's the
god of emotional, rapturous creativity,
where you get drunk, you have a lot of
sex, and then you express yourself,
okay?
And for the Greeks, these are two
aspects of creativity that you both need
in order to fully achieve your human
potential. Yes,
you need to be engaged in meditation and
rational analysis, but you also need to
fully explore the possibilities of your
emotions, to just let go, to be crazy,
be frenzy, okay? And what Virgil is
saying is that we must
the the Bacchus aspect is actually the
worst type of emotion, because it leads
you into madness, okay?
All right.
So,
um
K- K- Keep reading, uh Ivory.
Alas, you sailed Aeneas before he said a
word. So, you traitor, you really
believed you'd keep this a secret, this
great outrage? Steal away in silence
from my shores. Can nothing hold you
back? Not our love, not the pledge once
sealed with our right hands,
not even the thought of Dido doomed to a
cruel death.
>> Okay, stop. Okay. All right. So,
this line, not the pledge once sealed
with our right hands. This is an
allusion, of course, to um
All right here. Okay. This is an
allusion, of course, to the Odyssey,
where
Odysseus and Penelope meet again for the
first time in 20 years.
And
Penelope basically says to Odysseus,
convince me that you actually know my
husband. And Odysseus says, well,
because of this uh
ornament that Penelope gave to Odysseus,
right? And that ornament, of course, is
the pledge
sealed with their love for each other.
And this pledge, this memory, this bond
is what carries them for eternity, so
that even though they are a great
distance from each other, their hearts
are still conjoined together.
And so, what Dido says is, does this
pledge mean nothing to you, Aeneas? And
Aeneas, of course, is like it it's a
word, it's nothing.
All right? What matters is
your oath to the gods. What matters is
your loyalty to the gods. All right. I
K- Keep Keep reading, uh Ivory.
Why labor to rig your fleet when the
winter's raw, to risk the deep wind, the
north wind's closing in? You cruel,
heartless, even if you were not pursuing
alien fields and un- unknown homes, even
if ancient Troy were still standing,
still, who'd sail for Troy across such
heaving seas?
You're running away from me.
Oh, I pray you by these tears, by the
faith in your right hand. What else have
I left myself in all my pain? By our
wedding vows, the marriage we began, if
I deserve some decency from you now, if
anything mine has ever won your heart,
pity a great house about about to fall.
I pray you, if prayers have any place,
reject this scheme of yours.
Thanks to you, the African tribes,
Numidian warlords hate me. Even my own
tyrants rise against me.
Thanks to you, my sense of honor is
gone, my one and only pathway to the
stars, the renown I once held dear.
In whose hands, my guest, do you leave
me here to meet my death? All right.
Okay. So, two things to to remember,
okay? The first thing is
that in the Odyssey,
the journey, where it ends, the
destination, is towards home, to be with
Penelope again, to be a family again,
okay? And that is the end of this epic
journey.
But, in the Aeneid, it's reverse, where
you start off
with a relationship with love. And then
you have to abandon love in order to go
on this epic journey to to found the
empire of Rome, okay? So, you see how
it's it's inverse now.
In the Odyssey, the entire purpose
of your life is to return home and to be
in love, to fall in love, okay? But, in
the Aeneid,
love is what you have to abandon in
order to fully fulfill your destiny,
okay? That's number one. Number two is
this.
What
um
um Dido is saying is, thanks to you,
I've lost everything, okay?
So, love, my love for you, means I have
to abandon my pride, my reputation, my
own people.
Without love,
Oh, sorry. Because of my love for you,
I've become nothing, okay? And this
inverses the inversion
of what happened in the Odyssey, where
because Odysseus sought glory and fame
in war, he became traumatized with PTSD.
He saw the horrors of war, where
innocent people, innocent uh families
were destroyed
because of of war, and that traumatized
him. And what allowed him to resurrect
himself, what allowed him to escape his
trauma and rebuild his sense of identity
is going home and finding love again.
And this love is able to resurrect his
worldview and give him the courage and
the power to fight on, okay?
So, this is the the opposite message of
the
um
Odyssey, okay? All right. Let's Let's
So, now, okay? So, uh Dido is saying to
Aeneas, you're abandoning me. You
tricked me. I fell in love with you, and
now you're abandoning me.
And this is
um an Aeneas response. And And the human
thing to do would be to show pity,
right? And say to Dido,
Dido, I'm really sorry for what
happened,
but
let's go together. Or maybe, Dido, I'll
come back for you, okay?
Instead, he says the worst thing
possible. All right. Can Can Can you
read it?
Guest, that's all that remains of
husband now.
But why do I linger on until my brother
Pygmalion batters down my walls or I
have a strat me off his slave?
If only you'd left a baby in my arms,
our child before you deserted me.
Some little Aeneas playing about our
halls whose features at least would
bring you back to me in spite of all. I
would not feel so totally devastated, so
destroyed.
The queen stopped, but he, warned by
Jupiter now, his gaze held steady,
fought to master the torment in his
heart.
At last he ventured
>> in his heart is not sadness,
but anger, okay? Keep on going.
At last he ventured a few words.
I You could have done me so many
kindnesses and you could count them all.
I shall never deny what you deserve in
my queen, never regret my memories of
Dido, not while I can recall myself and
draw the breath of life. Okay, keep on
going.
I'll state my case in a few words. I
never dreamed I'd keep my flight a
secret. Don't imagine that, nor did I
once extend a bridegroom's torch or
enter into a marriage pact with you.
Okay, so what he's saying is
I We didn't We did not have a marriage
pact, okay?
We're not married.
This is not true. They consummate their
relationship and everyone witnesses it,
so they are married. But he's saying,
"We're not really married." Keep on
going.
If the fates had let me free to live my
life, to arrange my own affairs with my
own free will, Troy is the city, first
of all, that I'd safeguard. Troy and all
that's left of my people whom I cherish.
The grand palace of Priam would stand
once more. With my own hands I would
fortify a second Troy to house my
Trojans in defeat. But not But not now.
Grynean Apollo's oracle says that I must
seize on Italy's noble land whose
listening lots say, "Italy."
There lies my love, there lies my
homeland now. If you, a Phoenician, fix
your eyes on Carthage, a Libyan
stronghold, tell me, why do you grudge
the Trojans their new homes on Italian
soil?
What is the crime if we seek far-off
kingdoms, too? All right, so what he's
saying is this.
Dido,
um if it were up to me,
I would say we I I would say we'd do
either, okay? If it were up to me, I
would be back in Troy, dying and
fighting and dying for what I truly
love, which is a city of Troy. Now that
I've lost Troy, I must build an empire.
You have your own empire, Carthage. Why
stop me from building my own empire in
Italy? Okay, so what matters is not
love, what matters is power.
That's why we live, that's why we exist,
to seek more power.
Love gets in the way and therefore love
must be discarded. You, Dido, I do love
you, but you're in my way, therefore get
out of my way.
All right.
All right, so now Dido is distraught.
She fell in love with Aeneas and broke
her
vow to her former husband, Sychaeus.
And [snorts] now she knows
her people
don't respect her anymore
and she knows that the neighboring
warlords
have contempt for her and they might
even attack her because previously she
rebuffed their advances, so they feel
insulted.
Um but at the same time, she's still
desperate in love with Aeneas.
And she knows he can't He can't She
cannot stop him from leaving for Italy.
And so she decides eventually that her
only solution is suicide.
But she has a sister, Anna, who'll keep
watch over her. Okay, so she develops a
very elaborate ploy to kill herself. All
right. Can Can you read Anna?
And now what shall I do? Make a mockery
of myself, go back to my old suitors,
tempt them to try again.
Beg the Numidians, grovel, plead for a
husband.
Though time and again I scorned to what
they're like.
Would then trail the Trojan ships, bend
to the Trojans every last demand.
So pleased are they with all the help,
the relief I lent them once.
In memory of my service, past stands
firm in grateful minds.
And even if I were willing, would the
Trojans allow me to board their proud
ships, a woman they hate?
Poor lustful, can't you sense it, grasp
it yet? The treachery of Laomedon's
breed
What now? Do I take flight alone,
consorting with crews of Trojan oarsmen
in their triumph?
Or follow them out with all my troops of
Tyrants throwing the decks?
Yes, hard as it was to uproot them once
from Tyre,
how can I force them back to sea once
more, command them to spread their sails
to the winds?
No, no, die. You deserve it. End your
pain with the sword.
You, my sister, you were the first won
over by my tears to pile these sorrows
on my shoulders, mad as I was, to throw
me into my enemies' arms. If only I'd
been free to live my life untested in
marriage, free of guilt as some wild
beast untouched by pains like these.
I broke the faith I swore to the ashes
of Sychaeus.
>> Wait, so again, the idea here is
for Homer, love is what gives you
strength. Love Love is what allows you
to resurrect yourself, okay? So the
metaphor is love is the
the
bow of Odysseus, right? Where
this
bow Odysseus has not touched for 20
years. But the moment he touches it, it
gives him renewed strength and he's able
to
assemble it very quickly and then shoot
the target, okay? That's the power of
love.
But here in the Aeneid, love is the
complete opposite where by falling in
love, you disintegrate as a person. So
when when we first meet Dido, she's a
proud queen. And now she is a complete
mess. She is emotionally falling apart.
She's being driven into madness. She's
like, "Should I go and beg the Trojans
to let me on their ship and be a slave
girl?" Okay? So it is the complete fall
of a queen. Okay, from a queen to
essentially to a slave girl. She's
seriously considering being a slave girl
if it just means being near Aeneas.
And ultimately she decides, "No, my only
option is to
die, okay?"
All right.
>> [snorts]
>> So she is contemplating killing herself
and the gods know this and so what they
do is they tell Aeneas in a dream, "Get
out of here because we don't we don't
want you seeing Dido kill herself,
okay?" Can Can you read Anna?
Such terrible grief kept breaking from
her heart as Aeneas slept in peace on
his ship's high stern.
>> Okay, so Aeneas slept in peace meaning
he doesn't care. Do you understand? He
was never in love with her. She was just
a plaything.
Keep on going.
Bent on departing now, all tackle set to
sail.
And now in his dreams it came again, the
god, his phantom, the same features
shining clear.
Like Mercury head to foot, the voice,
the glow, the golden hair, the bloom of
youth on his limbs, and his voice rang
out with warnings once again.
Son of the goddess, how can you sleep so
soundly in such a crisis? Can't you see
the dangers closing around you now?
Madman, can't you hear the west wind
ruffling to speed you on? That woman
plot spawns her plots, mulling over some
desperate outrage in her heart, lashing
her surging rage. She's bent on death.
Why not flee headlong? Flee headlong
while you can. You'll soon see the
waves, a chaos of ships, lethal torches
flaring, the whole coast ablaze if now a
new dawn breaks and finds you still
lingering on these shores.
Up with you now. And not delay. Woman's
a thing that's always changing, shifting
like the wind.
With that he vanished into the black
night.
All right, so Aeneas is running away,
okay? And Dido has resolved to kill
herself and this is her speech
um right before she kills herself, okay?
Can you read Anna?
You, sun, whose fires scan all works of
the earth, and you, Juno, the witness,
midwife to my agonies, Hecate, greeted
by nightly shrieks at city crossroads,
and you, you avenging furies and gods of
dying Dido,
hear me, turn your power my way, attend
my sorrows. I deserve your mercy. Hear
my prayers.
If that curse of the earth must reach
his haven, labor on to landfall, if
Jove's and the fates' command and the
boundary stone is fixed, still, let him
be plagued in war by a nation proud in
arms, torn from his borders, wrenched
from Ilias' embrace. Let him grovel for
help and watch his people die a shameful
death.
And then, once he has bowed down to an
unjust peace, may he never enjoy his
realm and the light he yearns for.
Never. Let him die before his day,
unburied on some desolate beach.
That is my prayer, my final cry.
I pour it out with my own lifeblood. And
you, my Tyrians, harry with hatred all
his line, his race to come. Make that
offering to my ashes, send it down
below.
No love between our peoples ever, no
pacts of peace.
Come rising up from my bones, you
avengers still unknown, to stalk those
Trojan settlers, hunt with fire and
iron, now or in time to come, whenever
the power is yours.
Shore clash with shore, sea against sea,
and sword sword against sword.
This is my curse, war between all our
peoples, all their children, endless
war.
>> Okay, endless war, okay. All right. So,
the Aeneid is first and foremost
political propaganda.
All right? And so,
um,
Rome's epic war is with Carthage.
Rome and Carthage fought for about 100
years for control of the Mediterranean.
Ultimately, Rome will triumph over
Carthage,
and they will destroy Carthage as a
civilization. They will burn Carthage
down.
And today we have no memory of Carthage,
be so complete was the destruction.
And
um,
Virgil is trying to explain to us why
this had to happen.
It had to happen because Dido put a
curse
on Rome,
and forced her people to go to war with
Rome. So, it's not that Rome was vicious
and savage in destroying Carthage. It
was like the Carthaginians had a curse.
They had a mission to avenge Dido. Okay?
So, let me explain to you how this
propaganda works.
In Carthage's
uh understanding of Dido, she's the
founder, she's the queen of Carthage.
What happened was that, you know, she
Her husband was killed in Phoenicia, so
she and some refugees sought refuge in
northern Africa. So, they founded the
city of Carthage.
And they worked really hard to build the
city, and she was very attractive, so
she
um won the attention of some local
warlords, and they demanded her hand in
marriage. And her response was to kill
herself.
And by killing herself, that her
sacrifice emboldened her people to build
a great city, but also, um it won the
respect of the local warlords as well.
And from then on, everyone understood
the Carthaginians as a free and proud
people who would rather die for their
liberty than than become slave. Okay?
So, that's the Carthaginian
understanding of Dido.
Here in the Aeneid, it is almost the
reverse, where Dido
uh Dido's love for Aeneas becomes a
poison. It poisons her soul, and it
leads her to poison her people as well,
and rather than give them freedom, she
enslaves them into a mission to avenge
her. Okay? So, it's basically inversion.
All right? So, that's what
the Aeneid is doing. It's inverting
Homer, but it's also inverting history
to serve the local purposes of Rome.
All right.
All right. So, we come to the ending of
the um
uh Aeneid. So, with the with the story
of Dido, what what Ver- what Virgil is
doing is inverting the story of the
Odyssey. Now, we come to the ending of
the Aeneid, and here Virgil is going to
invert the story of the Iliad. Okay?
Remember, recall what happened in the
Iliad, where Achilles tricks Patroclus
into sacrificing himself, and this
allows Achilles an excuse to enter the
battlefield against Hector. He kills
Hector,
and he believes that this is the height,
the apex of his glory. But instead, it
causes him in- to fall into a deep
depression. It's really Priam
Priam's willingness to forgive him
because of his love for Hector that
frees
Achilles from his guilt.
And the two, Achilles and Priam, cry
together, and they become friends
because of this. Okay? So, the Iliad is
fundamentally a story of the curse of
power,
the evil power, and the ability of love
to both redeem and to save.
What Virgil's going to do is take the
story of the Iliad and invert it, okay?
So, it So, it ends actually with
um
with an analogy to the battle between
Achilles and Hector, okay? So, in the
Iliad it's between Achilles
and Hector. But here, it's going to be
between Aeneas
and Turnus. Okay? So, what happened is
that Aeneas lands in Italy,
and the Latin tribes see Aeneas as a
great hero, and the king there, Latinus,
marries
his daughter to
um
Aeneas. But
the wife,
for whatever reason, like the woman in
the in the um Aeneid are all the
villains, okay?
The the wife, the queen, has already
promised her daughter to Turnus, who is
another warlord. And this So, this
starts off a war between the Trojans and
Turnus, okay? And ultimately, this leads
to a final conflict, a great battle
between Aeneas and Turnus, okay? So,
this is the very ending
of the Aeneid. Okay? Okay, can you can
you read um I read
As he hangs back, the fatal spear of
Aeneas streaks on, spotting a lucky
opening he had flown from a distance,
all his might and main.
Rocks heaved up by a catapult pounding
city ramparts never stormed so loudly.
Never such a shattering bolt of thunder
crashing forth.
Like a black whirlwind churning on, that
spear flies on with its weight of iron
death to pierce
of the round shield with its seven
plies, and right at the thick of Turnus'
thigh it was it through.
It strikes home, and the blow drops
great Turnus, and the blow drops great
Turnus down to the ground, battered down
on his bent knees.
The Rutulians spring up with a groan,
and the hillsides round grow back grown
back, and the tall groves far and wide
resound with a long-drawn moan.
Turnus lowered his eyes and reached with
his right with his with his right hand
and begged as a suppliant.
I deserve it all. No mercy, please,
Turnus pleaded. Cease your moment now,
or if some care for a parent's grief can
touch you still, I pray you,
you had such a father in old Anchises,
pity Turnus in his old age, and send me
back to my own people. Or if you would
prefer, send them my dead body stripped
of life.
Here, the victor and vanquished, I
stretch my hands to you, so the men in
Latium can see me in defeat. Lavinia is
your bride. Go no further down the road
of hatred.
>> Okay, all right.
All right, okay. So, again, this is a
rewriting of the battle between Hector
and Achilles. But in this battle, it is
Hector who wins, and Achilles is
basically begging for mercy. And what's
really interesting is that to beg for
mercy, uh Turnus basically uses the
words of Priam from the Iliad, right?
Remember what Priam says to Achilles is,
I kissed your hand. Have mercy for me.
Look at my face, remember of your
father, Achilles. Remember your father,
Peleus, okay? Same exact words, right?
Care for a parent's grief, okay?
And I stretch my hands to you.
All right? So, so So, basically,
Virgil's plagiarizing Homer.
But he's plagiarizing a way as to invert
and subvert Homer. Okay? So,
at at this point,
um Aeneas is drawn to pity,
right? Because his great enemy, Turnus,
has submitted himself before him. So,
in his heart he's like, "You know what?
I've defeated him. He's been destroyed.
Um he's lost face. He's lost
credibility. I can let him go.
I've won." Okay? And that's what he
wants to do. He just wants to let him
go.
But this is the very ending, okay? This
is the very ending of the Aeneid. And
the ending is surprising
because from for for many scholars, they
read this They're They're like,
"This is not an ending. This is too
abrupt." And they think like um
Virgil was not able to finish the
Aeneid. But what I will show you is
that, no, you're reading the the Aeneid
improperly, incorrectly, if you do not
believe this is the full ending, okay?
This is in fact the ending. Okay? Can
you read, I read
Aeneas, ferocious in armor, stood there,
still, shifting his gaze, and held his
sword sword arm back, holding himself
back to as Turnus's words began to sway
him more and more. When all at once he
caught sight of the faithful sword belt
of Pallas swept over Turnus's shoulder,
gleaming with shining studs Aeneas knew
by heart.
>> Wait, so like Pallas, Pallas is the
the version of Patroclus. Remember how
Patroclus died and that made rage
Achilles. Well, Pallas is a friend of
Aeneas who fell in battle to Turnus. And
Turnus, to celebrate his victory over
Pallas, stole the sword belt of Pallas,
okay? So, and Aeneas recognizes this.
Keep on going.
Young Pallas, whom Turnus had
overpowered, taken down with a wound,
and now his shoulder flaunted his
enemy's battle emblem like a trophy.
Aeneas soon his eyes drank in that
plunder, keepsake of his savage of his
own savage grief, flaring up in fury,
terrible in his rage, he cries,
"Decked in the spoils he stripped from
one I loved, escape my clutches? Never.
Pallas strikes this blow. Pallas
sacrifices you now, makes you pay makes
you pay the price with your own guilty
blood." [music]
In the same breath, blazing with wrath,
he plants his iron sword hilt deep into
his enemy's heart.
Turnus's limbs went limp [music] in the
chill of death. His life breath had fled
with a groan of outrage down to the
[music] shades below. And that's it.
This is the ending of the Aeneid. And
again, scholars are confused by this.
Like, how how could the
um
epic end like this? It's a very long
epic, 24 books, and it ends
with the death of Turnus and nothing
more.
And it's confusing because scholars and
lit and literary critics are taught to
believe
that a good book has
um an epiphany and a catharsis, okay?
Epiphany,
catharsis,
and a resolution.
Basically, a character recognizes
himself and changes for the better,
okay? It's It's almost like a death
and a letting go of the past.
And so, scholars read this and they're
like they're completely confused.
Where is the epiphany? Where's the
catharsis? Where's the resolution?
And the answer is because you're
misreading
the Aeneid.
First and foremost, it is a work of
political propaganda.
So, how has Aeneas changed as a person?
Well, the change is this.
Previously, whenever Aeneas has a doubt,
okay?
Okay? Like for example, he is
changing his emotions.
Each time this happened previously,
the gods had to intervene,
right? So, remember how
um
Aeneas is back in Troy and he's
witnessed the killing of his king Priam,
and he's really angry. And then he sees
Helen,
and he wants to kill Helen because he
understands that Helen is the cause of
all the
death and destruction in Troy. And he
wants to like just kill her, and then
what happens?
His mother, Venus, intervenes and says,
"No,
Aeneas, you must stop. There's a mission
for you. Go complete your mission." And
then Aeneas is like, "Fine, mother. I'll
I'll I'll go home." And then he goes
home
and he sees her um
uh his son uh Iulus.
He wants to return and fight the Greeks
because he doesn't He wants to protect
his city. And then Iulus
uh there's a sign from the gods uh Iulus
his hair is on fire, okay? It's an
image.
And this tells
um
Aeneas, "No, your son is destined for
great things. You must fulfill the
mission."
Again, when Aeneas is with Dido,
he just wants to stay stay with Dido and
build up Carthage. And so, Jupiter has
to send a messenger, Mercury, to tell
him, "No, Aeneas.
No. Go to Italy,
okay?" So, each time
that Aeneas went off mission or he has
his own ideas, the gods had to
intervene.
What makes this an epiphany, a
catharsis, a resolution is the fact that
here, when Aeneas wants to show mercy,
when in his heart he's like, "He This is
a pitiful man. It gives me no pleasure
to kill him. It gives me no glory and
honor to kill this pathetic man."
He recognizes, "No, I must kill him
because it is a duty. It's the
It is the will of the gods.
Now, he has become fully pious.
And that
is
the
epiphany.
Okay?
I must abandon all pity. I must abandon
all emotions. I must abandon my own soul
if I am to serve the gods.
He is now the perfect soldier.
And that's why
Virgil wrote the
um Aeneid because it is a piece of
propaganda. It's a piece of
brainwashing, indoctrination where you
read it and you go on the same journey
as Aeneas. And step by step, you let go
of everything that makes you weak, your
humanity,
your weakness, your desire to love
someone. Leave Throw it out. Your pity,
your sense of decency. Get rid of it,
okay? And once you do, once you have
cleansed yourself of all human emotions,
then you can serve the gods completely.
You are now fully pious.
And as such,
you can now complete your mission.
All right?
So, that's the power of the Aeneid. You
may not know what's happening, but as
you memorize it, because back then uh
the way to educate yourself was just to
memorize um
memorize the poetry,
you became Aeneas himself, okay? You
transform yourself from someone who was
a human
to someone who is now basically a robot.
Okay? Does that make sense? Any
questions?
Yeah? Can Can Can Can you Yeah?
Um
Yeah, I think it's true that like Aeneas
he didn't feel empathy towards um
Turnus because he killed him him later.
But
I I I mean I think that is still because
like he loved Pallas, his friend, who
was killed by Turnus. So, that's
also kind of feeling, right? That's an
emotion that and that's contributes to
Turnus's death.
So, isn't that
different from what you said about maybe
Aeneas being a robot and fulfilling his
fate?
Okay, yeah. All right, that's that's a
good point, okay? So,
um
your point is
well, Aeneas loves his friend Pallas.
And as a result, it's his love for
Pallas that drives Aeneas to kill
Turnus, right?
That's fine. That makes sense, but go
back to the Iliad,
right? Where Achilles is saddened and
angered by the death of Patroclus.
And he kills
Hector, right?
But then what happens? He falls into a
deep depression
because in his heart he recognizes that
you don't avenge
someone you love by killing someone.
That's not how the universe works.
You If you truly love someone, you do
not
turn the memory of that person into
hatred and violence.
You celebrate the person's life by being
open and generous with others, okay? And
this is something that Dante will will
explain. This is a very hard idea to
understand, okay?
But if you truly love someone,
love means that you cannot do something
evil. Love is pure good. If you do
something evil, it means you actually
don't love that person, okay?
Does that make sense to you?
If you truly love Pallas as a person,
you would not use him as an excuse to
kill someone.
All right?
Same thing with with with the Iliad
where Achilles thought he loved
Patroclus, but he was actually using
Patroclus as an excuse to kill Hector.
And in his heart he knows that.
All right? This is really confusing to
understand, but when we when we read the
Divine Comedy, it will make sense to
you.
All right? Okay?
All right, any more questions, guys?
Okay.
Yeah, so that's a great question, and it
shows you how
um
basically, in this world, this is a
world of anti-love.
Because
you've been you've been receiving an
education in utility,
right?
Obedience, compliance.
But what you have not received is an
education in love.
What is love?
How do we know we're in love? What draws
us to love? Okay, and that's what the
great books are about. The great books,
if you read Homer and Dante, they really
think deeply about what love is. Because
in love is where God is.
All right? Okay? So So again, by by
asking this question, what What What
you're really doing is revealing the
sort of education you've you've
received. When you're mind, you think
that what is right is one of utility and
where when when and one of compliance.
If Achilles, my best friend, died, then
I need to seek vengeance against the
person who killed him.
Okay?
But
I know it's hard to understand, but that
is But you've been brainwashed to think
that. That's not actually true.
If your best friend were to be killed by
someone else,
to demonstrate love to your best friend,
you would actually forgive that person.
Okay?
And I I I I know it's a hard idea to
understand, but when we when we read The
Divine Comedy, it'll become more
obvious, okay?
Okay. A- A- Any more questions, guys?
All right.
So, let me explain the plan for The
Divine Comedy, which we'll end the
semester with, okay? So, there'll be
four lectures
on The Divine Comedy.
So, I'll I'll be doing a lecture every 2
weeks.
All right?
And then, for the other classes, we'll
just be reading The Divine Comedy line
by line by line.
All right?
Okay. All right, so
uh we'll we start The Divine Comedy on
Friday, all right?
Very good.
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay. Do Do you have to understand?
Okay, it's very hard idea to understand,
okay? But it's hard it's hard
idea to understand just because I hate
to say this, but but but but you've been
brainwashed and